well this is
ee 380 uh recording at um
uh october 26th
and um this is uh uh
a presentation about the
uh the
semiconductor incubator group silicon
catalyst
about how to build a semiconductor
company
uh silicon categorist has a interesting
business model
for uh providing
incubator services and
a mechanism for keeping the
cost of building a semiconductor uh
bounded
in any case it's a great a great
group of people and we're going to start
off today
by
examining well their process and how it
all works
uh the uh
the ceo pete rodriguez is going to
provide a brief introduction and then
continue on
if you have if you're discussing
please uh hold your questions to the end
and uh
raise your hand when the time comes and
we'll uh go through your
uh your questions and listen to your
comments
in any case uh pete you're on
thank you very much thank you dennis and
thank you uh stan
380 happiness um i'd like to point out
the last time i gave a lecture
physically at stanford they shut down
the campus the next day
so i don't know i don't know if that was
me or covet but uh
um i'll introduce myself briefly
and then the the two presenters mark
ross who's going after me and raul
camposano
who's going after mark and then i'll
also introduce the other members of our
team that
basically drove to put this together uh
rick lozenski our founder and chairman
who's participated in 15 startups since
he left stanford in
82 83 and i've worked with
this is our third time working together
um
and uh swan who pushed us to do our
slides and
also has been an entrepreneur and angel
investor and co-founder of the
the battery at berkeley with rick uh so
thank you both for
driving this along with dennis and and
getting us up here and thank you for
creating great slides
so a quick introduction on myself i'll
also introduce mark and roll and mark
and roll if
if there's anything you want to add or
highlight that that i don't cover please
do so
um so i've 35 years in the semiconductor
industry
uh the first 10 were all the technology
i did a startup where
i was the head of engineering and the
startup failed and it didn't fail
because of engineering it felt as a
sales so
i went and got a lobotomy and went into
sales and i figured that next time that
i did a startup i
would understand that concept uh this is
my fourth startup
uh probably my last along the way i've
also uh i ran
a public semiconductor company and i ran
a billion dollar business for nxp
semiconductors
prior to semi-retiring for two years and
then uh joining silicon catalyst
uh let's see mark who's going next uh
stanford graduate i think both bachelors
and masters uh we
i won't hold that against you mark uh
and uh has had an amazing career
and has been one of the most valuable
advisors of the 180 advisors that we
have
from the semiconductor industry at
silicon catalyst mark has
worked as an architect for steve jobs at
next
he's worked as an architect for andy
bechtelstein at granite i believe
and then on at cisco and then uh
he later worked as a chief technical
officer for tj rogers
at cyprus so uh three crazy dudes really
smart and crazy dudes that you work for
and also you've done a bunch of startups
along the way and
currently are helping a couple two or
three our startups
so it's great to have you do the the
technical presentation there mark
and then raul uh was a professor in
germany
uh was recruited to come to the us i
guess you've done work at bell labs and
in other areas too raul
and uh they went off to do 20 some years
at synopsys including
cto uh a role is also an adjunct uh
lecturer i don't know what that means
you know english is not my first
language but he's also an adjust
a jump lunge lecture at stanford and uh
i hear his classes are very good so i'll
have to attend one one of these days
when covet is over uh and then raul has
done three startups since leaving
synopsis
and most recently his startup sage was
acquired by applied materials so
uh we'll be going after mark closing up
today's presentation so
i'm really honored to be on this panel
with these two fine gentlemen
and with that laura let's start the the
presentation please
so before i cover some of the details on
this slide um
if any of you are interested in in
starting a star
specifically a semiconductor startup but
really any technology stuff expertise
either technical expertise in the space
or
uh deep market expertise it would be
actually better to have both
if not in the one individual than in the
founding team
i think starting in areas that are not
your areas of expertise at just one more
level of difficulty in doing a startup
which is already quite difficult
the next thing i like to mention is that
um the number one thing that venture
capitalists
look at is market i had one vc tell me
20 years ago
that the three rules of real estate are
location and the five rules
of venture investment are market size so
clearly they like to see markets
and in one area one focus in this area
is that it's not you know we have
entrepreneurs uh
that put up slides and we've looked at
over 350 companies
in five years with silicon callus and
those show the iot market as you know 80
billion well clearly you're they're not
going with one chip
after the entire iot market so you
really need to look here that you're
specifically going to go after
what is the size of that um
there has to be a real pain in the
market and
uh like to point out that uh uh
if you get paid for solving pain
so the the other comment there is that
um uh
when is this pain gonna be solved if
you're gonna have a solution
in um in two or three years
is there gonna be a relevant pain that
you're solving there and you're solving
it superiorly to someone else
so if we go through the slide you got to
take a
concept of looking at the competition
you need to have guidance talk to
multiple advisors especially those that
are experts in this area experts and go
to market
you've got to talk to a lot of customers
and when talking with customers
it's really clear to understand where
their problems are going to be in two to
three years
um steep blanket stanford has put
together a program along with others
that the nsf peaches call and um they
insist that you talk to
100 customers now in certain solution
areas
there are more than 100 customers okay
and finally you need to talk to
investors
if i put this business plan together if
i can have this level of value
proposition if i can have this level of
pain solved in a uh in two to three
years
will you invest in this venture to the
customer will you buy this solution
and one of the most important things in
doing this analysis
is not what the customer tells you they
want but what the customer is willing to
pay
so that part is really really critical
and really difficult to ascertain
um and so um at x-star when i was
running that company
we acquired a startup called materia and
the terrain had come out
with the first or second 10 gig ethernet
solution they had received they had
gotten hewlett packard as a customer
they had received an offer for
acquisition for 300 million
and they turned it down by the way you
get a good offer like that just take it
you could always do another startup uh
in the second generation
they only listen to one customer
and i acquired that company for 11
million so
um listen to your customers really
figure out
where their pain point is going to be
when your solution is ready
uh and i think mark used the the quote
in his comments this slide is like
ringwetsky
uh wayne gretzky said sk
with the competition where the puck's
gonna be not where it is right now
so move where the competition is going
to be where the solution is going to be
at the time that you're ready to deliver
a solution
not where it is today and you've got to
have a clearly defined value proposition
if you're competing with an established
player
that have a significant advantage
probably 10x in order to win
so that's my guidance on all of this but
very clearly
get advice speak with customers speak
with investors
understand the market the competition
and where things are going to be at the
time
that um that you launched your solution
and one more point uh bill grows down
the southern california incubator king
uh did an analysis of 200 successful
companies 100 of his and 100 in silicon
valley
and the number one thing uh for success
was timing team was number two but
timing was number one
so the market window that you're going
to be hitting is very very important
okay i look forward to questions at the
end
on this let's move on to the next slide
please
okay so there are many questions to
identify
in building a semiconductor company
do you have a product worthy of building
a company so
if you look out into the future and you
say okay i deliver this product
i deliver this value proposition i have
10 customers that are buying it in
production
i am getting the following uh you know
price for my for my product uh and
that's
really difficult value pricing you can
do value pricing at the beginning when
you have a clear advantage
as you get others to compete with you it
becomes more commodity pricing
so um when all of that is said and done
when you create a picture of that
is that enough to drive a standalone
business
if the answer is no then you have to
determine okay
is this enough to get to cash flow
positive and create something that will
be of value for someone to acquire
second are there enough customers if
there's only two or three customers
then you have to at least win one of
them and it has to be sufficient to make
your business go
if the answer is no then you know don't
spend a ton of time and money
find something else and then where are
the companies today where are they going
to be in two to three years
is there anyone another startup that you
don't know about or in stealth mode
and that's where you have to go to
industry events
conferences and talk to people if you
talk to customers
they will typically know because those
companies are also trying to figure out
what what the answers are
okay our next slide please
so um what kind of company would you
like to build
so clearly in the semiconductor space
and today at silicon callus
we take any type of semiconductor
solution what we mean by that is a
chipless software
a chiplusa system or chiplus plus
a sensor or any combination of the above
and now we've extended that to
intellectual property and to mems and
sensors
typically a solution is more sticky
than just a chip so even if you have say
an interface chip that's going to go for
50 cents
if you have really good software drivers
those drivers will make that interface
more sticky than if you don't
uh clearly as you move up the value
chain in terms of
um solution the more the software that
you have
the the stickier your solution the more
valuable your solution
and the harder it is to replace from a
given socket
um in today's world in a lot of
commodity and semi-commodity products
you not only have to win the product you
know say at the system provider but then
you have to go
win it again at the company like foxconn
that's going to build it
and they operate on such thin margins
they're always looking to replace
commodity providers
with others at a lower price with
companies like apple
and microsoft and intel you're somewhat
protected because they define who
you can use um but still the more the
value that your solution has
the better the asking price you're going
to get the better the value pricing
so you want to be solving a key problem
for the customer
if it's just um if it's a minor pain
point
they may just power through it they may
not completely change their design for a
smaller company
uh and take that risk so really have to
solve a real
a real pain point okay moving on to the
next slide please
so um business plan and go to market
this is very very critical um
the all of these items will drive your
costs
and how much money you need to raise for
example
depending on the solution that you have
the expertise the problem you're solving
you may be able to raise a money with
powerpoint
so we have a company we recently talked
to that raised 20 million
uh with a powerpoint presentation that's
highly unusual
in 90 percent of the cases you're gonna
have to have a lot more than that to
raise money
and you're probably going to raise a
couple of million dollars in seed
uh to get to the next step which is
typically some type of minimum viable
product
or um you know prototype and it's much
easier to raise money with a prototype
as part of a system
so one more thing to drive here before i
get into the specifics of this slide
and that is today even if you're
building a simple interface product
that's 50 cents
uh you're gonna have to showcase it as a
in an entire system you're going to have
to have reference to science of how that
fits in with
with intel or apple or samsung or
whomever
that you're trying to sell into and have
a complete solution even with software
even if it's not a production worthy
solution but it has to be good enough to
show that your chip
works at the performance and and at the
data rate and so forth at the power
levels
uh so even the simplest products today
have to have a reference to sign along
with them
and that has to be part of your plan so
um but when you look at the product
there are many points here mark's going
to go through this in much more detail
than i am right now
so but clearly what the functionality is
the intellectual property from outside
that's going to require
what are the uh non-recurring
engineering cost to get it to production
uh what will your cost of goods be when
you're in production
and how will you go to market with it is
it five sales people
going to 20 customers is it a
distribution and rep network
is it a combination of the above um
and those are all key questions that
you're going to have to ask
and finally how do you really go to
market right and
uh for example i'll give you a
solid example at nxp we were doing 10
billion in revenue
we had a power business we had an
interface business but we wanted to go
into a charging area where we didn't
play
the cost of doing that even for a 10
billion dollar company that already had
customer relationships
was to build a prototype and we spent
several million dollars doing it
that was a little bit better than what
was available and it was only to get us
in the door of those meetings so they
would treat us seriously and say okay
here are the features we'd like you to
add for the next generation so depending
on the market depending on the customers
you may have to have quite a bit of
collateral in order to get in the door
and and take a chance at the next
generation
okay next slide
okay so why now um i think we've already
talked about this in the previous slides
but
your product development can easily take
two to three years oh i'd like to add
today
i'd like to add that there are different
markets with different time
constants if you're selling into
automotive it's in several years if
you're selling into communications
it's several years if you start at the
right point because if you start close
to when another cycle is going to be
when people are going to go from you
know 10 to 100 gig or whatever
uh you need to decide when you're going
to cut into that market
and then work back from that if it's uh
aerospace it could be longer if it's
consumer it could be six months
so each market that you go into has a
different time constant
and a different point that's that's
important for you making your decision
okay um and clearly
especially for digital designs but even
for analog designs for digital designs
you can build a prototype
and show people with an fpga plus you
know an off-the-shelf mic
or or a microcontroller already included
in that fpga
in analog in some cases you can buy
off-the-shelf products off-the-shelf
radios and other things to demonstrate
at least the high-level functionality of
your product
again it's a little harder to do that um
[Music]
but clearly you want to understand the
market win
and work back from that and make sure
you have enough slack that you're going
to be able to meet it because things
always slip
next slide please
okay so um i think we've already covered
this
and that is you want to hit the market
at the right time so you can maximize
the number of units
clearly um as the market becomes mature
you're going to be able to charge less
for your product so you got to have a
cost reduction strategy built in so that
you may
can maintain your margins or at least
get close to maintaining your margins
um okay next slide
typically most of the entrepreneurs that
we deal with
um are one or two uh
uh persons that are typically both
technical
uh clearly if you're gonna have a
company you need more than that
you need operations you need general
administrative um
you need um technology both creating the
current product
and looking forward to the next product
clearly when you're two guys in a garage
that's hard to do
but you need to have a plan for putting
together your team together
and you have to have a company in mind
when i get to this point and i have 50
employees
and i'm paying them an average of this
and cost of goods are costing this
i need to have a revenue of this plus a
profit of this and
all of those models have make sense and
every entrepreneur we talk to obviously
has a hockey stick in their plans
make sure that that hockey stick is
underpinned with with some reality
right as to what you can get for your
product in what time frame
huh you know a design one is very
important did i get a socket where
you know a socket on an iphone is vastly
different from a socket on a mac
vastly different from a socket on on
some microsoft or intel products
so um how sticky is that socket
you know how long will i be able to keep
it so these are important questions to
answer
and you need a solid team to get to
success
yes the market window may be the most
important
but you can't get to the market window
without a solid team so be thinking of
the team
what are your strengths and then what
are the complementary strengths that are
required
uh to build a good company
and now now i'll turn it on over to mark
uh to building an ic
thank you um thanks pete and it's
wonderful to be
here one thing that pete was saying that
is really important is that often
technologists which i am one we focus on
the technology and to pete's point
previously
a team a successful team requires a
number of different disciplines
and those disciplines are often in areas
that you don't have strength so that's
something to keep in mind
so what we show on this particular slide
is two different paths
to how to build an ic product he covered
the first one a little bit by saying
that depending on your type of design
you might actually be able to use
off-the-shelf components
to get to a demo a thing that reiterates
a point made earlier
is that that demo regardless of whether
it's the first or the second stage
the demo is an important proof point
it's a proof point both for yourself
and it's actually a proof point for
investors and
finally it's a proof point for customers
and that connection with the customer is
absolutely essential because they're the
ones that guide what you should actually
be building
so as i say the difference between the
top and the bottom flow here
is whether or not you can in fact use
off-the-shelf
components to go build the solution that
you're trying to do
but in any case you end up going through
the chip design that you're doing
the demonstration phase and finally the
go to market
so let's talk about the types of chips
that there are next slide please
so what i've done here is simplistically
i've defined
three types of chips that you could
potentially be building
one of them is analog and i'll mention
that pure analog chips are extremely
rare these days
you could have a digital design or you
could have a mixed signal
it's equally critical to note that every
chip
that you're building even if you think
it's purely digital
is actually analog underneath it nobody
bothered to tell the transistors that
they were digital
and in fact it's only through levels of
abstraction and constraints that allow
us to build a digital chip and treat it
purely digitally
so we'll talk about this in the next
slide and it's it's really talking about
the different layers that you've got i'm
going to go through this
a couple of times in the different flow
so what you see
here is architecture through to the
masks
or the physical design that you're doing
on the right hand side what you see are
the tools that are helping you
to move from one layer to the next and
on the left what you see over here are
the tools
that are helping you to verify that
transition as you move from one layer to
the next
so with the architecture phase for
example uh build up please
so what you see at the architecture
phase that's one of the phases where
you often have custom tools so by custom
tools i mean that you may write c-level
models of what it is that you're trying
to build
and at that point you may go into a
high-level synthesis
so you have different methods of getting
to the register transfer language if
you're building one that has digital
design in it
or going to the circuit design phase but
again at each one of these stages you
have either synthesis
some kind of a tool that is helping you
to move from one phase to the next
on the verification side build up please
on the verification side there is
equally a large number of tools
that are helping you to validate that
each one of these layers
is actually functionally correct as you
move from
say register transfer language to the
circuit design
next slide please
so what you see here the point about the
tools is that
there are a huge number of tools that
you're going to end up using
as part of your design process and in
fact
there are 30 categories of eda tools
defined by the esda
these are in the levels that we said the
verification and the synthesis
there's a lot of them one point that i
would make in here
that i think some people overlook is
that stitching together these tools and
some of the custom tools that you will
need to write
in order to be able to display to
analyze the data that you get from one
of these commercial tools
is going to be an important part of your
process
so don't think that just because you've
got a set of tools
that you're done you're going to need to
figure out how to get those tools to
work together as one cohesive block
next slide please
back to the flow picture that we had i'm
showing a different view of it here
i call this typical but as
anybody that's built chips will know
there is no such thing as
a typical flow what we show in moving
between these various phases is a set of
arrows on the bottom
that are the linear flow where you
design an architecture
you code up the rtl you synthesize it it
creates gates
you move into a layout phase and then
ultimately you take the chip out
it goes to fab get through test and
debug test automation
you sell it make a lot of money
everything is wonderful
the problem is that the real world
doesn't work this way and what you see
on the top
are a number of back arrows that show
you moving from a
phase that you were at to a previous
stage and
as the arrows are showing you can
actually move all the way from
layout back to architecture it's rare
and if you've done your job right
you shouldn't have to do this but keep
in mind that that backwards flow
is a part of this entire process it's
also critical to note by the way that
when you're moving through this flow the
most important thing that i can suggest
that you do
is tape out early and often and what i
mean by that silly expression
is not that you actually tape out your
chip multiple times
but that you get through the entire
process
as early in the design flow as you
possibly can
and the reason for this is the whole
concept of unknown unknowns
you don't know what you don't know until
you get all the way to the tape out
phase
similarly frankly when the chips come
back what you need to be very careful
about is if something doesn't work the
way that you expect it to
keep in mind that if it's a digital chip
for example
you may have mistakenly thought that
everything in that chip was digital
but if you had a phase locked loop in it
if you had a certies if you had
something else
there's an analog block at work there
and if something's going wrong
make sure that you go back and test the
assumptions
that were built into it that suggest
that you can
box that in in a particular way next
slide please
so what we're going to do at this phase
is switch gears a little bit and talk
about a couple of scenarios and give you
three examples
and the point of this particular slide
is that you have a line chart on the
bottom
that is showing each one of the phases
that we talked about
and the duration that you would go
through for each one of those phases
so again you're seeing a linear
progression of time on the bottom
the orange graph that you see here is
the per month expenses
i want to emphasize here that this is
labor cost only
and this has become a theme later but
what we're doing here is we picked a
reasonable staffing and a reasonable
cost per engineer
and so what you have here is that the
costs per month are going
up and down and there's a cumulative
cost that's happening
in this slide now one point that i will
make this is going to become obvious
when you get to the next one
is that if you look at the monthly
expenses you'll note that they go up but
that they
also come down this is
possible if you structure your company
in a way where you have contract labor
so that means that when a particular
phase is done you can actually no longer
need that person so you're not paying
for them so
next slide please if you look at this
second scenario what we're doing here
is this one is i'm not necessarily going
to suggest that either one is more
realistic than the other
but this is a different timeline where
the first three phases instead of taking
three months are taking six months each
it also is different because what you
see here
is what i'm calling accumulating staff
so what i mean is this
if every person that you bring into the
company is an employee
and you're paying them you're paying
them whether they're doing
whenever you get them in you're paying
them the people that were doing
architecture during the rtl in the
synthesis phases
now what i've done very successfully is
that the architects are often
the ones who know how the design is
built better than anyone else
so you can often use them in other roles
such as verification
they're a wonderful resource for that
next slide please so now what i wanted
to do is to shift gears and show you
three different examples so
these are emphasizing that what we were
showing in the scenarios are
realistic so this first example is taken
from a silicon catalyst portfolio
company
that i actually know quite well it's
showing you that they spent
longer than what we've listed before in
the architecture phase
so figuring out what it was that they
were going to build
their rtl and synthesis phases were
about what we've shown before
and what you see here is that their
expenses definitely do go down so they
were following that model of using
contract labor for it
now a thing to keep in mind here is this
is an example
where in a span of a couple of years
they have spent roughly two million
dollars in labor
as the ceo of termito said he believes
that with reasonable funding and he
defined that as
3 million a team of 10 people
can get a chip done in two years so
that's something to just
let that soak in that it's roughly three
million dollars
and a couple of years to get done now
let's go to the next example please
so this one is a chip that was mostly
analog
another company i'm familiar with what
you see here
is a completely different set
of phases so this was a company building
a device that was mostly analog
and so for them they did system and
circuit design
during the first phase then they moved
to a layout post layout sim
and then finally the verification and
testing this was an extremely small
team so you notice that the cumulative
dollar spent on this
is quite a bit lower than the scenarios
that we've shown or the previous example
it also shows that they were able to get
to a chip
in 12 months one thing that i should
emphasize on this is
the accomplishment is absolutely
incredible
this was a test chip however and so one
of the things that you need to separate
in your mind is the difference between
something that validates what you want
to do and something that you can
actually sell to customers
next slide please so in this
third example what we have is a chip
that is
almost exclusively digital with the
caveats that i've mentioned
before and again there's a little bit of
a repeated theme here that while we said
that in the longer scenario it takes six
months
most of these companies are showing that
it is
around six months to go through the
architecture phase
and in this example they have
i don't know that i had quite accurate
head count on this
so this again is a less expense but keep
in mind this is only showing you
the 12-month window so everything
including tape out frankly is not
included for this particular
example next slide please
the the last part after showing you
these examples that i wanted to do is
this is a way of
reminding me with these three icons of
some important considerations for you
and so they're just memory tricks for me
so that i could remember what it is that
i should be advising you at this point
the first one on the left is kind of
obvious the one
on the far right is less obvious and
we'll get to that in a minute
checklists are an important part of
designing these ics they're a way of
capturing the collective
understanding both as a company grows
and progresses
but also the knowledge base that you
come in with from the people that you
put
on your staff so a checklist the one
critical point to keep in mind is that
checklists are a means to an end they're
not the end
i've worked in companies where people
end up getting
overwhelmed with checklists and they
get to the point where they simply
follow the checklist and believe that by
following the checklist
they're doing the right thing the
checklist is there as think of it as a
guard rail
it's not there to tell you what to do
it's there to help you
to avoid some mistakes that you might
make
the second icon that i've got here is
intended to show you that you're
managing risk
one of the companies that i was
privileged to talk to about 15 years ago
managed their entire company by this and
what i mean and what they meant
by risk is that you take what you're
building
break it down by a lot of the subtasks
and identify
whether those subtasks are unique and
the difficulty level associated with
them
and part of what you get from that is a
non-linear score
and manage your company by trying to
drive down
that overall risk what this does is it
forces you to focus
on areas that are difficult and it makes
you focus on them early
rather than focusing on them late it's
very easy to get caught up in
making progress but not necessarily
making
real progress and the third icon i told
you i would get to that
the third icon was meant for me to tell
you
that this is as i said to the people
joking at the beginning
that everybody needs a pony in their
particular presentation
and what i mean to show here is that no
successful company that i know of is a
one-trick pony
so what you need to do here is realize
that in
building a company what you're doing is
building this whole process
of going through a build measure learn
loop you're going to do this multiple
times and what you want to do of course
is to get
better as you go along so with that i'll
turn it over to raul
yes so um when we started silicon
catalyst
roughly five years a little bit over
five years ago
it was a time when investment in
semiconductors was actually
fairly low in particular venture
capitalists were
very reluctant to invest in chip
companies
because there was a feeling that chips
were becoming more and more of a
commodity number one and number two
there were alternatives investments
which were much less risky
this is epitomized perhaps by apps which
which could be built in a very short
period of time you could get to a
demonstrate or a first viable product
in a matter of months while as we just
learned from what mark showed you right
it takes a few years to actually build a
chip
and so we decided well obviously
innovation is necessary
in semiconductors we need semiconductor
solutions we need chips
and and so what can we do
to remedy that situation one of the
first things we did is we went out
and we interviewed a lot of startups
and semiconductor companies and asked
them what are your issues
so if you just look at the issues they
look all
pretty much equivalent right there's
none that stand out
dramatically if you look a little bit
closer right you see that
um as a matter of fact eda and
lab tools which are of course necessary
to
design chips and and the prototype
builds are
a little bit um more weighted
than all the other issues that you go
there but once you go to expenses and
challenges actually the picture becomes
much clearer
if you look at expenses right one of the
key things is of course
raising money the second thing is
managing your time of course
the longer it takes to design a chip the
more likely you are
to um to run out of money and if you
look at the challenges right then
very clearly eda tools and
their silicon prototyping are the things
that dominated
and so we went and thought what what can
we do
to to help with this
and next slide please and the answer is
actually
pretty obvious right if we can provide
the tools which are pretty expensive a
typical
tool set to design a chip a
state-of-the-art tool set depending on
um depending on exactly what you get
right can cost several million dollars
and so if we could provide the tools for
free
the intellectual property chips these
days are built not only by
designing from scratch but the large
majority of the areas typically occupied
by things like memory
cores and arm core and maybe a risk five
core
ios that you don't build
again you you reuse them and if we could
also provide for free
um not only the tools and the ip but
also a
path to fabrication a spot on a
multi-project wafer
then a company would need to raise much
less cash next please
than if they had to fund all this if if
you if you had to fund all this eda
ip the testing of the chip and the
fabrication
of the chip you're going to spend most
of the capital that you raise
not on just the team but also in
acquiring all of these
if however an incubator could provide
all this as an in-kind contribution
then you need much less cash
the rest you raise as in kind and the
cash that you spend
as is illustrated there in red
goes towards actually hiring the people
and developing the product and not so
much
into essentially spending on things that
that are collateral that are absolutely
necessary
but that don't really contribute to
making your startup more
or less successful anybody can buy these
things
so what we did next please in silicon
catalyst
was um we went to the industry
and next we went
to the industry right and we recruited
income partners now
this is a result after five years we
started with very few
but if you see we have different
categories of in-kind partners that
provide their tools or services or goods
for free or for a very steep discount to
a company that wants to design a chip to
our portfolio companies right and
examples among them that are really
important rda companies you see synopsis
there you see mentor there ansys
silvaco so you can get their tools for
free
for up to two years which is a good
period to get started perhaps a good
period to actually
get into a prototype in terms of ip
we provide um the two
most prevalent cores here arm and risk
five in the form of sci-fi we also have
synopsis
r courses and all their other iop which
is great if you go to services we have a
few companies
um that actually does services that can
help you design your chip
perhaps the other the second most
important one after eda right which was
the fabrication of the chip we have tsmc
which
gives you free shuttles if you're
building a company
so you can get a prototype build and st
which is one of the most
advanced mems producers right if you if
you're doing a chip which require mems
or if you're doing a mem solution right
you can
use sd to prototype that and in the same
vein
we have we have in-kind providers which
help you with the test and which help
you with
business perhaps interesting right we
provide time in the cloud amazon is a
partner of us so you can get
aws hours for free to run
your tools to do your designs we also
partner with rescale which has a couple
of tools in particular
the ansys tools and the mentor tools in
the cloud so you don't even need
computers you can just
run them in the cloud next
this has resulted in
a lot of companies we have over 30
portfolio companies
and many of them and they're listed here
actually come out of universities you
can
spot if you look carefully there two of
our portfolio companies which came out
of stanford
but we also have portfolio companies
which came out of mit
which came out of cornell which came out
from
um montreal we have several companies as
a matter of fact in canada
etc so if you are
um thinking of building a chip company
silicon catalyst is a great place to
start because we will
provide you with all the in-kind with
all the collateral that you need for
designing a chip and we'll also connect
you of course to an ecosystem of
over 100 advisors that have been there
have done that that know how to design
chips and know
also how to commercialize them and and
how to figure out what is your market
and how to hit the market properly as
pete was explaining in the beginning
next
and i think that was it join us in
driving innovation
silicon catalyst is there for you if you
want to start
a semiconductor solutions company or a
chip company
thank you
thank you roll thank you mark isers
because of our excellent relationship
with stanford
with professors like dennis uh with kurt
peterson with rick barr
with boris with uh mark horwitz with a
lot of the folks at stanford
uh i think in our network there's
probably four or five that regularly
lecture at stanford
um that we would provide office hours
uh to talk with the entrepreneurs that
are interested in putting together a
company and providing advice as to
you know what they should do next before
they jump hot and heavy into
uh into building a startup so and with
that i think that concludes uh
the presentation thanks again to uh to
dennis and to mark and roll
over back to you dennis
thanks so much are there any questions
out there
i have one and uh it relates to a
project i'm currently
involved with and that is uh how do you
guys deal with that
people who want to build things which
don't use a standard process
what do you have in mind exactly is this
is mems related or is
this um or let me take a shot at that
a part where uh the actual process does
not
utilize uh design rules and that sort of
thing
uh by any of the founders
tough question uh
you think about it bro well i'm trying
to answer here um
so clearly tsmc as the largest and
highest volume
uh and most of the vance foundry doesn't
really like to
do anything custom we have gotten them
to do implant changes and a few other
things
uh sometimes you can get them to do
non-custom things by the way that you
make your mask and so forth but but
we also have relationships with global
foundries and with smaller foundries
some that are official partners
and some that are unofficial like global
um so we would talk with you and we
would try to figure out where it would
make the most sense
and a lot of the smaller foundries are a
lot more uh you know flexible
in terms of doing these things but again
it's it's never easy it takes
yeah well that that's the answer i
expected and uh would have been
surprised if you'd said otherwise
but uh this positions the the
uh silicon catalyst project process
into uh basically building parts out of
uh out of uh known quantities
uh in the most efficient way which is
perfectly reasonable
i like to add that in the men's arena
clearly
there's no one foundry
tsmc in mems right st is considered to
have perhaps the best foundry and
they're our partner
bosch also has a very good foundry and
they're our partner and there are other
foundries around the world that do mints
and so what we try to do is find what
the company is trying what the startup
is trying to build
and then tailor it to the capabilities
of a foundry and then go work with them
but in some cases you know it's a lot of
work at the foundry too so in some cases
they're not going to do it for free
or they're not going to do it but we
definitely give it a good shot and we've
been quite successful at getting
startups into mem's foundries
that never before they would have gotten
in yeah so
i won one of the companies that was
there on the slide that
and came out of stanford zeno right they
actually don't um use a standard process
they start
they try to use as much of a standard
siemens process as possible but they're
trying to do like a
one cell one transistor um ram
which is static ram right which which is
of course a very different thing of what
the industry is doing right now
and they've been in the incubator for
for a while right we've connected them
to um both foundries right and customers
that are that are interested in that
kind of thing and they've they've made
some
some progress so we we have done um
we've done things like that right but it
it it's much more difficult
if you don't need new materials if you
can use the fab as is
and and all you're doing is is changing
the design rules and perhaps um
doing something a little bit um
a little bit different than than using
just a run-of-the-mill pdk
that works fine if you want to introduce
new materials and
and and and
a different manufacturing process that
becomes a lot more difficult of course
yeah so does that does that mean that
[Music]
you guys are not staying right at the
bleeding edge of semiconductor
technology but
in operating in an area where things are
uh
are more stable
no i think it's different right to look
at that
one thing is material innovation which
um
which which is um of course very
interesting right and then process
innovation
but that is much more difficult right
than than actually
constructing system and silicon and our
main goal is of course um
enabling companies that that want to
that want to do a solution in in
semiconductors using existing processes
not so much develop new processes
makes sense uh sure i was wondering in
your experience which is the greater
risk
the risk of not delivering to the plan
the execution risk right not delivering
the chip that you intended to build
or the risk of uh trying to build the
wrong chip that ship that the market
doesn't want
i would say that uh based on a lot of
experience
building the wrong chip is the most
common
right even even at large companies yeah
yeah even at large companies uh
i seen uh people trying to build a clown
ship
with everything but the kitchen sink in
it you know
and first of all bringing it um it's not
competitive because it'll use too much
power it'll use too much uh
you know too expensive from a silicon
area
and yield so i think the the most common
is
building the wrong product and that's
why we focus so much on
talking with customers and i didn't want
previous questions
i find it in that context i find it
strange that you know been on the
entrepreneur
side of the table probably
over 100 vc meetings by this time uh and
almost all of those conversations all
focus on the execution risk and i just
find that
strange i think they all
they all believe that if you have the
right team
that you will find the right product i
think the collective experience among
all of the people here says that that's
not always the case um the other point
that i would make that i think is
important to note of what pete's saying
is back to the timing question you can
build exactly the right chip and if you
build it five years too early or you
build it even a year too late
it's the wrong chip so it can be wrong
for
reasons of it's got the wrong feature
set or it could be simply that your
timing isn't at the right point
yeah i wanted to add comments
to to dennis's first question which is
um we are we have expanded beyond
the initial launch with silicon to
semiconductors we've expanded to
intellectual property we've extended the
mams and sensors
and we are considering expanding into
materials we're not there yet
our joint venture in chengdu china has
already
expanded to materials for power
like right so
carbide and so forth uh but we have not
uh decided to make that step but we're
seriously considering it
uh and then the other thing is we'll go
out of our way to help the startups
we have a major uh tier one foundry
that's not csmc where we've been able to
negotiate
sometimes even at the ceo level uh to
get basically production assets
discounted and then converted to equity
for the startup companies
so uh you know when you when you talk
about changing processes
you know we'll we'll we'll take a chance
at negotiating pretty much anything
we're not always successful
right the more custom the harder it is
but uh but we'll do that
i think we covered everything
i thank you guys for uh for giving the
presentation
i hope uh you uh
your your wisdom uh finds a
welcome ears somewhere and things will
work uh
work very well for you